okay so two things one this episode
finally made me cry I'll go more into
that in a second but - there's something
I forgot in the last V log dad I can't
believe I forgot to mention this by I'm
just gonna mention it real fast just go
into a little talking about it and that
was Zuko story his side of going through
this metamorphosis and I just want to
say real fast like that was that was
very nicely done and I think some people
do underestimate what it means to so
dedicate yourself to something and then
when you finally pull out of it or you
make a choice to pull out of it for
something that you've been attached to
for so long can have physical
representation of a broken heart I mean
it's not that that really happens that
often but that same kind of idea that
you can allow yourself to actually get
ill when something is missing so I
thought that was a very clever way to do
that on top of that one of my favorite
scenes happen when he looks in the
mirror and in his dream and he sees
himself as the avatar first of all
that's very interesting he read a lot
into that but my favorite bit is that he
wakes up and he touches the scar on his
face and he closes his eyes and I love
that moment because at the exact same
time he was both relieved and
disappointed again that he had that scar
and to me that's like the whole that's
the transformation that's like that's
like a perfect moment that's feeling
everything that's feeling this great
relief and this great pain both at the
same time and I love moments that can do
that those are the most effective
moments to me not just the ones of
incredible sadness or incredible joy but
the ones that can get that perfect
combination and I don't know how I
forgot to bring that up in the last one
but I'm bringing it up here so okay
enough of that let's talk about this
episode the Guru and that's somebody at
the door excuse me that's my dad
he interrupted this big v-log shame on
him but
I'm talking about how important it is to
connect and have that perfect connection
to life and family in relationship and
then he comes in and it all up
hell's wrong with him God doesn't get
anything it's like right in front of him
so anywho um okay so let's let's talk
about the Guru uh this is actually I
think this is my favorite episode
actually uh and I told you before that
add the this teary-eyed moment okay I'll
get to that a second they remind you if
you don't know what this episode is uh
this is when Aang travels to the grew
that we saw earlier the one that came
across Appa oh I'm so glad he was back
you know I said I'd be totally content
if that's all they showed of him but I
they brought him back and they totally
use into the full advantage and this
whole episode much like the last one
with Zuko was sort of this metamorphosis
uh it's sort of the same thing here with
Aang this is uh very much him going
through the spiritual journey maybe a
little quick but again half hour you
don't know he'll twenty-four minutes you
gotta speed it up you gotta rush it for
24 minutes and all the other stuff they
had to fit in there they do a very good
job
and again they deal with these great
ideologies and philosophy and psychology
and and energy instead all of us love
this stuff I love the idea of I me
probably talked about I probably talked
about before just the idea of evolving
and the idea of the human animal is an
animal but we're one of the few animals
they have the capacity to be more and
that's done through here not as much
through the rest of us well Navin that
it's opening this up to open up
everything else so bla bla bla it's just
too much philosophy there um so Aang
goes to this Garuda uh to help himself
open up to the world he's going through
a metamorphosis Zuko is clearly going
through a metamorphosis I mean he's
actually like happy it's actually kind
of unnerving you're not you
to saying it but it is very refreshing
and you feel good you like seeing him
smile you like seeing him contempt I
love that one final image where he's
just sweeping and he's happy it's like
that's all he needs just doing his
simple job and that adds a good feeling
um a tough goes through this great
metamorphosis as well she figures out
how to bend metal and which I'm sourcing
to us like wait they can't bend metal
isn't that just you know really really
processed earth
I started get out you couldn't quite do
sand either I or the sandbenders or
whatever that's made them go into that
um but so she goes through a
metamorphosis and again the great
azula's plan a wonderful plan where
which is you know infiltrate then get
captured to make it seem like somebody
else has the advantage when really she's
calculating it on everybody's giving her
the information she needs and I can't
wait to see what they do with it I don't
care achter um so all wonderful stuff
osaka sees his father again so much
happens in this episode and and it's all
done so well and it's so great um he's
gonna go fight with the men until the
end egg has his Empire Strikes Back
moment and realizes that he can't
continue with training because his
friends are in danger
yeah pretty similar but it it works I
guess um I guess that's one of the
things we saw had to her ah I don't know
I I get it I get it Aang is told you
know like the love of his life is can
possibly be killed and if he leaves now
he can never have the what was that he
can never have the Avatar state or it
might be lost forever and he goes anyway
maybe that's the test
I don't know they go after the loved one
anyway I doubt it it'd be cheesy if they
did that but ma they could work it
around some sort of philosophy I don't
know but um so he's going back to that
to go and try and save her and has Sokka
with him
so okay so what's the big moment that
finally got me to yeah I didn't cry at
the storm I didn't cry at at the uncle
out by the tree with his dead son I
didn't cry they missed out you're not
gonna believe the moment that they gotta
tear out of me it's it's so you're gonna
laugh but it did and I kind of know why
but even now I'm trying to process it
it's the moment where after it was he
letting go I think he was letting go of
his guilt or or a shame owada they're
very very much tied together and
throughout this whole time he has to eat
this onion and banana porridge the this
onion and banana soup or whatever it is
and once he is fun and eats complaining
do I really have to keep having this
data yes ha ha that's funny you don't
like it ha ha anyway keep going and the
Guru has a good sense of humor about it
and he gets closer and closer to opening
up these these chakras uh he does this
one where it's like like I say it's
releasing a large part of his pain and
he releases it
he gets teary eyed and he says can I
have some more onion and banana soup
Indian I don't know why
something about that line did me in
there's just something about the way the
actors said it that kid was so opened up
it's like he's so like now he let go of
all his pain and now he wants that thing
that he hated a second ago and I I don't
know what it is I'm not you go look up
the line just so I can quote it exactly
because I don't think that's the attack
line but the intention and the idea it's
here's the line right there I'll put it
in later
and it's just I don't know why that line
got me there's I really like I said
earlier I really like these moments
where that perfect that perfect pain and
that perfect joy really come together
and I really felt that sort of capture
that hill sort of this release and it
was so comforting strangely comforting
that's such a strangely comforting line
and I know it's the most bizarre moment
to get teary eye that but that's what
did me in so yeah there you go avatar
made me cry like a even at the
moment when Rob was saying like yeah I
dare you to watch the tales of Ba Sing
se and not crying like a you know
it it I got through it it was very
touching but I got through it this is
the one that got me so and I I'm sorry
it's such a funny line to get trapped by
but it worked it really worked and again
a lot of it does come from the actor
that the boys delivery of it which was
so good and so hard fun I'm wondering
what the what was written in the script
or what the director told him to get
that delivery because that was just like
each perfect delivery and you know
they're all good actors anyway but I
mean that was just pitch perfect so uh
and a wonderful ending again we sort of
have Zuko seems to be finally content
and finally happy again I love this
stuff just what it's all about to
crumble down and it's all about to hit
the fan and as ULA's gonna destroy it
all sick sick side of me who he's
probably gonna get flung right back into
his so yeah um and I love the
ending just with her doing that little
smile where with with Zuko smiling and
then her just being led away with that
little smirk on her face just everyone's
coming it's gonna lead right into her
plan and it's just oh it's it's very
entire strikes back so I get wonderful
episode right probably my favorite
action
we uh I love The Metamorphosis stuff I
love the Enlightenment stuff I love the
evolving stuff I love
it shows the process of it I love the
stuff with the story and how much is
going on I love the relationships and
this I love the emotions in it love it
all so um again that's uh I'm gonna make
some onion and bananas too cuz that's
what I'm in the mood for now so see the
next Monday